in this lesson you are going to
understand the concept of recommender
systems by the end of this lesson you
will be able to build a recommender
model using Python describe the
mechanism of Association rule mining
demonstrate a priori algorithm so let's
go ahead and understand recommender
systems in detail so what is a
recommender system and how is it useful
many e-commerce and retail companies
implement recommender systems on their
websites to leverage the power of data
and boost their sales in other words the
goal of a recommender system is to
predict users interests and recommend
products that the users may be
interested in data required for
recommender systems stems from explicit
ratings that users provide after
watching a movie or listening to a song
from implicit search engine queries and
purchase histories or from other
knowledge about the users items
themselves recommender systems are one
of the most successful and widespread
applications of machine learning
technologies in business it is an
information filtering technique that
provides users with recommendations that
they might be interested in as you can
see in the given image interests of
users a/b c/d are given your
recommendation system has to find out
whether user II will be interested in
music or not let's look at how
recommendation systems are useful in
day-to-day life recommendation systems
acts as a solution for many of your
day-to-day choices such as which website
will you find interesting which degree
or university is best for your future
which is the best investment for
supporting the education of your
children which digital camera should you
buy which book should you buy for your
next vacation which is the best holiday
for you and your family before we
explore this topic let's think of how a
recommender system recommends items to
users
it recommends items that are more
popular among all the users it divides
users into multiple segments based on
their preferences that is user features
and recommends items to them based on
the segment they belong to in the given
example you can see that when you go to
buy a book on Amazon it recommends books
that are frequently bought together and
also gives you insights under customers
who bought there is also about this
let's understand the purposes of a
recommender system prediction
perspective it predicts to what degree a
user likes an item it is the most
popular evaluation scenario in research
interaction perspective it educates
users about the product domain
conversion perspective it looks for
commercial situations such as increase
in hits and click through and also
checks lookers and Booker's rate
retrieval perspective it reduces user
search cost and effort by providing
correct proposals or recommendations
recommendation perspective it identifies
items from longtail where users don't
know about their existence
paradigms of recommender systems
recommender systems reduce information
overload by estimating relevance as
shown in the given image a recommender
system matches the relevance of the
recommendation component with the
recommendation list and based on the
relevance it decides the recommendation
what our personalized recommendations
the most relevant item is recommended
based on the user profile and contextual
parameters every day massive amounts of
information are generated and the
existence of a large amount of
information makes it difficult to find
the required information personalized
recommendation is the process of
alleviating the problem now let's
understand how a recommendation system
finds what's popular among your peers
collaborative filtering recommendation
algorithm uses the rating data to
calculate the similarity between items
it does not consider the semantic
relationship between different items
let's understand what content-based
recommendation is it is used to display
products similar to the products you
have liked before a content-based
recommender works with data provided by
the user either explicitly through
rating or implicitly by clicking on a
link based on the data provided by the
user it generates a user profile
suggestions are given to the user based
on this the recommendation engine
becomes more and more accurate as the
user provides more inputs or takes
action on the recommendations knowledge
based recommender systems use knowledge
about users and products to make
recommendations about which product
meets the users requirements a
knowledge-based recommender system does
not have a ramp-up problem as it does
not create recommendations based on user
ratings since knowledge-based
recommendation systems judgment is
independent of individual tastes it does
not have to gather information about a
particular user these characteristics
make knowledge-based recommenders not
only valuable systems on the
our own but also highly complementary to
other types of recommender systems
let's now understand how your
recommender system can make combinations
of various inputs and/or composition of
different mechanisms hybrid recommender
system is a system that combines
content-based filtering and
collaborative filtering and takes
advantage of both the representation of
the content as well as the similarities
among users it is also possible to use
the recommendations of the two filtering
techniques independently collaborative
filtering part a collaborative filtering
systems make recommendations based on
historic preference of the user such as
items clicked watched purchased liked
rated etc user item matrix can be used
to present these preferences it uses
filters either based on item based
nearest neighbor or user based nearest
neighbor let's understand user based
collaborative filtering well user based
collaborative filtering recommends items
by finding user similar to the active
user as in the given example based on
other users you need to determine
whether Alice will take the by five
which is not seen or rated by her let's
understand how you can measure user
similarity using Pearson correlation
degree of linearity can be determined
using Pearson correlation in other words
it determines whether there is a linear
component of association between two
continuous variables as such Pearson's
correlation has no assumptions about
linearity however when you already know
the relationship between your two
variables is not linear you would
normally not want to pursue a Pearson's
correlation to determine the strength
and direction of a linear relationship
let's understand the given formula in
the given formula a and B are the two
users and you are asked to find the
similarity between them the given
formula will give you the result between
negative 1 and 1 where 1 means highly
similar and negative 1 means not at all
similar in the given formula a
and be our users our AP is the rating of
user a for item P P is the set of items
that are rated by both a and B now you
have the similarity between different
users for a specific item use these
similarity values in making predictions
so a common prediction function is given
on the screen here sim a B is the
similarity value obtained for users a
and B are B P is the rating of user B
for item P collaborative filtering Part
B now let's understand how item based
nearest neighbor works item based
approach is preferable to user based
approach so what is the reason behind
this preference because of the dynamic
nature of users user based approach is
often harder to scale as the items
usually don't change much item based
approach often can be computed offline
and served without constant retraining
KNN is the perfect go to model to
implement an item based collaborative
filtering it is also a very good
baseline for recommender system
development look at the given example in
item based collaborative filtering you
need to look for items that are like
item 5 and then take Alice's ratings for
these items to predict the rating for
item 5 the choice of the K nearest
neighbors for the neighborhood formation
results in a trade-off when you use a
very small K only a few candidate items
can be recommended because there are not
a lot of neighbors to support the
predictions while the particularity 's
of users preferences can be blunted due
to the large neighborhood size so a very
large k impacts precision the optimum k
also depends on data characteristics
such as sparsity so k is set to be in
the range of values from 10 to 100 the
similarity is measured based on two
algorithms cosine and adjusted cosine
cosine similarly has better impact in
item to item filtering
here ratings are seen as a vector in
n-dimensional space so the angle between
the vectors is used to calculate the
cosine similarity
whereas adjusted cosine similarity takes
average user ratings into account and
transform the original ratings
Association rule mining at a basic level
Association rule mining involves the use
of machine learning models to analyze
data for patterns or co-occurrence in a
database
it follows Association rules which is to
identify frequent if-then associations
given a database of transactions each
transaction is considered as a list of
items it finds all the rules that
correlate the presence of one set of
items with that of another set of items
it identifies the frequent patterns it
is most commonly used for Market Basket
analysis Association rules are created
by searching data for frequent if-then
patterns using the criteria support
identifying the most important
relationships support is an indication
of how frequently the items appear in
the data it provides a fraction of
transactions containing the item x and y
support is calculated as the number of
times item x occur divided by the number
of transactions confidence indicates the
number of times the if-then statements
are found true it indicates how often
the item x and y occur together given
the number of times X occurs it is
calculated as the number of times items
x and y occurred divided by the total
occurrence of X a third metric called
lift can be used to compare actual
confidence with the expected confidence
it indicates the strength of a rule over
the random co-occurrence of x and y it
is calculated as the number of times in
x and y occurred divided by total
occurrence of x multiplied by total
occurrence of Y Association rule mining
Market Basket analysis let's understand
the Association rule using the given
example
market basket analysis is a modeling
technique based upon the theory that if
you buy a certain group of items you are
more or less likely to buy another group
of items and items set is the set of
items that a customer buys and Market
Basket analysis is used to find the
relationships between purchases here in
the given example a B C D and E are
items in a store P is the set of all
transactions that are P 1 P 2 P 3 P 4 P
5 so you can see that each transaction
is a set of items consider you made some
Association rules using the given
transaction database support is a
measure of how much the historical data
supports rules defined and confidence
mean confidence mean is the measure of
how confident we are that the defined
rule holds true support can be
calculated as the fraction of rows
containing both a and C or joint
probability of B and C among the rows
containing a confidence is the fraction
of rows containing D or conditional
probability of B given C this is the
ratio of confidence to support if the
lift is less than 1 then a and D are
negatively correlated else positively
correlated if it is equal to 1 it is not
correlated so when you are calculating
support confidence and lift values will
result in the given matrix
shishun rule generation a priori
algorithm candidate item sets with the a
priori algorithm are created using only
the large item sets of the previous pass
the large item set of the previous pass
is joined with itself to generate all
item sets with a size that's larger by
one each generated item set with a
subset that is not large is then deleted
the remaining item sets are the
candidates it uses frequent item set to
generate Association rules frequent item
set is a set of items whose support
value is greater than the threshold
value with this approach the algorithm
reduces the number of candidates being
considered by only exploring the item
sets whose support count is greater than
the minimum support count a priori
algorithm example part a
you
the number of item sets that have to be
examined can be pruned using the a
priori principle the list of popular
item sets can also be obtained we have
the given data of a store scan the
transaction database to get the support
s each one item set compare s with min
sup and get support for one item sets
let's assume the support value is create
the item of the size of 1 calculate
their support values as you can see here
item 4 has a support value of 1 which is
less than the main support value so we
are going to discard 4 in the upcoming
iterations we have the final table F 1
start with item sets containing just a
single item determine the support for
the item sets remove the item sets that
do not meet your minimum support
threshold and keep the item sets that
meet it use join to generate a set of
candidate K item sets use a priori
property to protect the unfrequented K
item sets from this set next create item
sets of size 2 and calculate their
support values all the combinations of
items set in F 1 are used in this
iteration item sets that have support
less than 2 are eliminated again in this
case 1 2 the length of an item set is
extended all the combinations of item
sets in f12 are used in new candidate
kisi 3 now let's understand what is
pruning and how it makes a priori one of
the best algorithms for finding frequent
itemsets using pruning we are going to
divide the item sets in c3 into subsets
and eliminate the subsets that have a
support value less than 2 a priori
algorithm example Part B scan the
transaction database to get the support
s of each candidate K item set in the
given set compare s with mints up and
get a set of frequent K item sets using
sets of f3 create c4
since the support of this item set is
less than two we will stop here in the
final item set we will have as f3 with
f3 we get the following item sets for 1
equals set 1 3 5 subsets R 1 3 1 5 3 5 1
3 5 4 1 equals set 2 3 5 subsets are 2 3
2 5 3 5 2 3 5 we will create rules and
apply them on item set f3 now let's
assume that the minimum confidence value
is 60% for every subset s of I you
output the rule s is greater than is
means s recommends is if support I over
support s is greater than or equal to
min call you a priori algorithm rule
selection based on the steps performed a
few rules have been selected and a few
are rejected so all the rules that are
selected have a confidence value greater
than 60 percent for set 1 3 5 look at
the rules rule 1 set of 1 3 greater than
set of 1 3 5 - set of 1 3 means 1 & 3
greater than 5 confidence equals support
1 3 5 over support 1 3 equals 2 over 3
equals sixty six point sixty six percent
greater than 60 percent
hence rule one is selected rule 2 set 1
5 greater than set 1 3 5 minus set 1 5
means 1 & 5 greater than 3
confidence equals support 1 3 5 over
support 1 5 equals 2 over 2 equals 100
percent greater than 60 percent rule 2
is selected
rule 3 3 5 greater than set of 1 3 5 -
set of 3 5 means 3 & 5 greater than 1
confidence equals support 1 3 5 over
support 3 5 equals 2/3 equals sixty six
point sixty six percent greater than 60
percent rule 3 is selected explain
specifically why each and every rule is
selected and rejected rule 4 set of one
greater than set of 1 3 5 - set of 1
means 1 greater than 3 & 5 confidence
equals support 1 3 5 over support 1
equals 2/3 equals sixty six point six
six percent greater than 60 percent rule
4 is selected rule 5 set of 3 greater
than set of 1 3 5 - set of 3 means 3
greater than 1 in 5 confidence equals
support 1 3 5
over support three equals 2/4 equals 50
percent less than 60 percent rule 5 is
rejected rule 6 set a 5 greater than set
of 135 minus set a 5 means 5 greater
than 1 in 3 confidence equals support 1
3 5 over support 5 equals 2/4 equals 50
percent less than 60 percent rule 6 is
rejected this is how you create rules in
a priori algorithm and the same steps
can be implemented for the item set to 3
& 5 demo user movie recommendation model
problem scenario consider the ratings
data set below containing the data on
user ID movie ID rating and timestamp
each line of this file represents 1
rating of 1 movie by one user and has
the following format user ID movie ID
rating timestamp ratings are made on a
five-star scale with half star
increments user ID represents the ID of
the user movie ID represents the ID of
the movie and timestamp represents the
seconds from midnight coordinated
Universal Time or UTC of January 1 1970
here you are supposed to predict a user
movie recommendation model let's import
the required libraries
and the data set also add column names
against the data set
let's now print the resultant data frame
since we are developing a user movie
recommendation model we must be aware of
the number of users and the number of
movies so let us write the code for the
same
you
now we will split the data into training
and testing sets importing the Train
test split function from the SK learn
dot model selection module first create
a 0 matrix with dimensions as n
underscore users and underscore movies
now that we have created train and test
sets we will populate the train and test
metrics with ratings such that the user
ID index - movie ID index equals the
given rating
we can now see that we have some movie
ratings in the training set we will do
the same for the testing set
you
now import the pairwise distances import
from SK learn documentation to non zero
vectors of an inner product space that
measures the cosine of the angle between
them the cosine is 0 degrees is 1 and it
is less than 1 for any angle in the
interval 0 PI radians now we will go
ahead with the predictions based on the
fact that user movie collaborative
filtering x' difference from mean rating
is a better indicator than absolute
rating
calculate user predictions such that
user prediction is the sum of the mean
user rating and the dot product of user
similarity and ratings difference
divided by the absolute value of the
user similarity the matrix we received
as output describes how those unrated
movies will be rated by users based on
their prior rating styles
you
now that we have approximately generated
ratings for all movies let's quickly
recap the steps we have covered import
libraries and the data set identify
total number of users and movies split
the data into training and testing sets
populate the Train test Metra sees with
the random ratings create cosine
similarity metro sees for users and
movies perform predictions
this brings us to the end of recommender
systems you are now able to build a
recommender model using Python describe
the mechanism of Association rule mining
demonstrate a priori algorithm
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here